normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government but
let's jump to this story from cnr.com
scanner Missouri AG launches
investigation into Media Matters AG
Andrew Bailey quote I'm fighting to
ensure Progressive tyrants masquerading
as news outlets cannot manipulate the
marketplace in order to wipe out free
speech this is huge Attorney General
Andrew Bailey says we have reason to
believe Media Matters has used fraud to
solicit donations from missourians in
order to bully advertisers into pulling
out of X the last platform dedicated to
free speech in America we have launched
an investigation and it is quite simple
according to data from X as well as
numerous reports Media Matters appeared
to have created fake accounts or created
Created dummy accounts using new
accounts following specifically
advertisers and extremists that way the
content would appear next to each other
and they could then go to The Advertiser
and say see look your content appears
next to extremists which is which is a
disingenuous version of events that
being the case for Media Matters to
claim this thing happened when according
to x their staff and Elon Musk it
happened like two times the argument is
Media Matters is defrauding donors by
tricking them into thinking they are
actually solving a problem when in fact
that problem doesn't even exist
therefore the argument now is fraud this
is huge but this is the law fair and
it's not just Missouri I know that I
believe uh Texas is is filing several
suits too right a state the attorney
general attorney general there is doing
that yes let me let me let me read the
letter here so we can get the uh uh the
the specifics Here Andrew Bailey of
Missouri says this letter serves as a
formal document hold notice under
Federal and Missouri law the Missouri
attorney general's office has opened an
investigation into Media Matters for
America regarding your firm's
potentially unlawful business practices
full stop Media Matters is a I believe
they're a 501c4 nonprofit I could be
wrong but they all they do all day is
watch what they view as conservative
media and then post things often times
they're out of context or manipulative
but here's more he says as you are no
doubt no doubt aware a federal laws has
been filed against Media Matters raising
serious allegations that your firm
falsely and deceptively manipulated the
algorithm on X formly known as Twitter
through coordinated inauthentic behavior
and that you did so in an attempt to
defame the organization and C cause
advertisers to pull their support from
the platform thus harming Free Speech
the lawsuit alleges that you lie to the
public falsely suggesting that Fringe
extremist content regularly appears next
to content from corporate advertisers
when in fact the opposite is true at the
same time you appear to have used his
coordinated inauthentic activity to
solicit charitable donations from
consumers across the country I have
reason to believe that your firm's
alleged actions may have violated
Missouri consumer protection laws
including laws that prohibit nonprofit
entities from soliciting funds under
false pretenses I'm especially concerned
that Media Matters actions if proven
true have hampered free speech by
targeting an expressly pro- free spee
speech social media platform in an
attempt to cause it Financial harm while
defrauding missourians in the process
you are thus hereby instructed to
preserve all records that may relate to
your alleged effort to engage in
coordinated inauthentic behavior on
social media Platforms in or in order to
generate false statements that were used
to solicit charitable contributions
under false pretenses you are instructed
in particular to preserve all records
that may relate to your web page which
expressly solicit funds at the following
URL he then goes on to list several
other documentation that must be
preserved so this is a notice to
preserve documents which means the
investigation is about to begin Missouri
expects to get into the discovery phase
and it mer very well may be that as we
enter 2024 the law fair ramps up
substantially more than just private
actors filing lawsuits and on top of
Missouri we may see I I got to be honest
I wouldn't be surprised if every single
state AG has some kind of lawsuit fired
away in an attempt to Advantage
themselves in this election it's not
just about votes it's not just about
vote policy it's about speech
capabilities yeah it's it's about Media
Matters trying to take down X and now
Missouri fighting to defend X because X
is in favor of free speech 2024 is going
to be absolutely wild it already is wild
I know I'm just saying it's going to get
crazier it's going to get way it's not
just Media Matters it's so many other
organizations like that that exist and I
mean they could be you could make an
argument that they're doing the exact
same thing so this is really I think
this is huge this is really big to to
set this sort of precedent for you know
we will come after you if you try to
influence uh you know defraud people
essentially I mean that's the argument
they're making here and you know you
look at these other outlets like you
know right-wing watch uh what's the
other one the big one Patriot takes and
other ones like that where they take
things out of context and they could be
doing the same thing I don't know I mean
it it's worth if they solicit donations
yeah so Rumble is suing uh check my ads
I believe the two Founders and what this
group does is they contact advertisers
for various conservative outlets and
then try to get the advertisers to pull
out I can say they have made numerous
deceptive statements about us and used
that to solicit donations notably they
claimed that I pushed the quote unquote
big lie which is a CLA uh the big lie
refers to Donald Trump saying he won in
2020 anybody who's ever watched this
show knows that I've never claimed Trump
won 2020 and I actually argued with
twice that Trump lost because people did
not like him and they want they didn't
vote for Biden they voted against Trump
and Steve bennon actually went huh
that's that's I said Trump got anti-
elected there's no enthusiasm for Biden
they were voting against Trump and he
goes that's pretty good anti- elected
yeah so I'm like the fact that they
would raise money off of making that
claim it shows these organizations are
deceiving people in order to raise money
for the record they're a 501c3 Media
Matters is Media a C3 no no no no no yes
I know they're according to wik
Wikipedia they're 5 exemp from federal
income tax so how does that change this
at all does it make it more or less uh
501 c3s can't engage engage in partisan
political activity yeah and it's pretty
clear that they are
very super packs typically I believe
they're 501 C4s that's the tax
designation 501 then the season the
parentheses and a four and uh uh this
501 C4s don't have to disclose where
their money goes but it's not tax
deductible and uh 501c3 is completely
tax deductible but you can look up all
their information their salaries uh I
recommend everybody do this search for
tax form 990 and insert nonprofit and
you can learn a lot about all these
organizations so good SL uh good sleo
thing uh everyone out there have
fun uh am I supposed to say something
now Med you made the noise I look for
990 media matter I was like I'm one of
those guys I want to know I want to know
who who owns it who runs it who makes
the money how much salaries that's good
and and and there's a lot there's
restrictions on this stuff so should be
interesting but uh I'm curious to see
where all these lawsuits end up but uh
regardless you know it's not even 20124
yet okay primaries haven't happened
we're a month away from the Iowa
caucuses and already people are starting
to get crazy it feels crazy did you guys
hear CLA Schwab and I think this video
is real he said that he was railing
against anti-stem and saying that there
was Liber the biggest threat to the
system is Libertarians the
libertarianism it's it's it's like on
Twitter it was freaking me out like is
it's like this is the maskoff moment if
this is a real video and he's speaking
out against libertarianism people who
believe in Freedom are the biggest
threat wait he had he had a mask on to
freedom to Freedom that's literally what
they say I love when they tell us to our
faces what they're trying to do like it
just it it just it drives home the point
that like they're not even they know
they don't have to be silent about it or
they think they have more power than
they do well it's because the average
person doesn't care that's true I can't
I can't tell you how many people I've
met who go oh well I don't I don't want
to I don't pay attention to that stuff
there's a viral video where this woman
is like I just went to Chipotle and my
burrito bowl was 1982 I know I got guac
but that should make it 1982 like WF is
going on and it's like well as you sit
there not paying attention uh your
burrito blls are becoming very expensive
now for those of us that are paying
attention we're like perhaps it was the
several hundred billion dollar spent in
foreign war garbage over the past couple
years and the massive spending that's uh
resulted in hyperinflation I shouldn't
say hyperinflation it's being a little
hyperbolic but you get my point it's
either or you know giving everyone
$2,000 checks and big corporate bailouts
that's that's also another big issue
another big problem that of course I
think a lot of people need to uh deal
with as well but we are not in a in a
good situation there is a lot of law
fair now some people say there's too
much law fair I I would kind of agree
with them but right now it is very
heavily one-sided it is essentially
district attorneys financed by George
Soros it is essentially a lot of the
leftist organizations and groups that
are kind of organizing themselves and
suing and attacking everyone Alex Jones
was sued for a billion dollars Elon Musk
is being sued by those same individuals
right now so we we are sadly living in a
day and age where lawyers are becoming
more important but also uh more powerful
and more Rich than they ever were before
since this is how we are seeing this
kind of asymmetrical Warfare being waged
politically in in a very d ous Gambit
that is not good for America it's not
good for its people and sadly now
everything you do and say has to be
carefully monitored you have to watch
yourself you make one mistake you're
going to get sued into into Oblivion and
uh this is why the appeals case for
what's happening to Alex Jones is so
important as of course they they they
they found him guilty and he owes a
billion plus dollars for speech which
found liable but this is the important
distinction here is that there was no
trial people don't know this y people
are being told Alex Jones Lost a lawsuit
and is forced to pay over defamation no
he didn't it was R it was a ruling in
default the judge said no trial for Alex
Jones you owe them you owe them now
we're going to have a hearing determine
how much you owe them and he couldn't
defend themselves and the major
accusation was that he didn't uh provide
Discovery uh but ACC according to Alex
Jones he was providing Discovery he was
providing a lot of the documentations
that they were asking said that no
matter what he gave them they kep say it
wasn't it and that's like how how do you
like it's like torture you know the
torturer says tell me the location of
the Genesis device and the guy goes I
don't know so they hit him again tell me
or else I seriously don't know he's
lying and they keep hitting you it's
like if you don't know what are you
supposed to say just lie so they're like
we want these documents and Alex's like
well there you go okay we want more he's
like that's it nope there's more you're
lying and he's like that's all I have
and they're like no default you lose
well that's the danger of this litigious
societ in it's kind of what we've we saw
with Roger Stone too they did the same
thing to him they accuse him of lying oh
you didn't turn over all the emails or
you did this and therefore you tried to
lie about this and he was like no that's
not what happened uh but they can keep
pushing you and they can keep pushing
you and they can keep it in the court
system and they can keep making it not
only uh you know a a matter of like the
court but also the court of public
opinion too like they can keep you under
their thumb that way and they'll just
keep telling you you're lying you're
lying you're lying and then they make
you into a monster publicly and in the
court as to who you really are and
that's kind of what happened with Alex
Jones it happens with a lot of people
but I I think you're totally right this
litigious Society we live in is so
dangerous because it's like at what
point do do we stop because if they're
if the enem is going to be doing that
right if they're going to be throwing
lawsuits at everybody left and right
then our only way to defend ourselves is
to throw lawsuits at them in response
which is what you're seeing for example
in Missouri I bet you artificial
intelligence will take that task on
they'll start using artificial
intelligence to counter Sue and Sue and
counter Sue and it'll just you see up
magnitud more oh yeah there's going to
be AI writing like court documents it's
going to be so weird thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net